i do take the president at his word and
the president's other agenda was never
linked to the infrastructure effort
mitt romney always of generous spirits
don't give them the veneer of
bipartisanship on what is
a heavily partisan agenda democrats keep
getting caught up
in their own vision of what america
should be as opposed to what america
is and this is particularly true with
regard to joe biden's agenda so over the
weekend we saw this bizarre situation
which joe biden once again
i mean he is not all there and it is
perfectly obvious at this point that he
is not all there
because he makes comments and then his
team has to rush out of the wings
and wheel old joe back feed him his
cream of wheat put him down for a nap
and then they have like ron klein come
out and clarify what exactly
he meant or they put out a written
statement where joe biden can't fumble
over his own words and get into a
physical fist fight with the
teleprompter
it's insane so you remember that late
last week on thursday
there was a group of republicans and
democrats and job and they all came
together at the white house and they
announced they had a bipartisan
deal on infrastructure and kamala harris
was creepily hanging out
like behind a pillar kind of staring at
uh
at the man whose job she will eventually
take don't be a food taster at the white
house gang it's a bad
bad job okay so you remember that and
you remember they announced we have a
bipartisan deal and then within just a
couple of hours
joe biden was out there saying well yeah
we haven't we have a bipartisan deal
on this part but i'm i'm not gonna sign
that unless
we also pass through reconciliation
this giant builder can everybody won't
wait hold up
that's not a bipartisan deal then if i
say to you
i promise to buy from you this this used
car and you say i'm willing to sell you
this used car i say yes i will buy from
you this used car also
i insist that you sell me your house at
a price i want to pay that's not a deal
you've now changed the deal
so joe biden did that and there's a lot
of consternation on both sides of the
aisle
it looked as though he had undercut mitt
romney and susan collins and all the
rest of the republicans cause all the
rest of the republicans were like um
here we are holding the bag out here
and we came out here on behalf of
bipartisanship and you used us in order
to have your photo op and then you just
undercut us so no deal
right behind closed doors i am sure sure
that what republicans were saying
to biden was listen if you insist on
this being part of a package deal
we're not going through with any you're
not going to get past the filibuster not
only that we're not going to vote for it
so then joe biden had to walk it back
according to the new york times it was
all going according to president biden's
tightrope plan to pass the most
ambitious economic agenda in generations
right until the moment that mr biden a
politician with a history of rogue
comments
veered off script understand the reason
that biden did this is because he's more
afraid of aoc and bernie sanders than he
is
of his actual base and the people who
are closer to center left or the people
who just want to get things done in a
practical way he's scared crapless
of the radical democrats saying that he
is insufficiently submitted to the
committed to the cause because remember
joe biden's agenda he knows he's not a
two-term president
if he makes it through a first term and
if he runs for a second term he
certainly is not making it through a
second term
so he knows he's not making it eight
years so it's i need to be a historic
president
right here right now and if i'm deprived
of that by these republicans who are
filibustering
then i'm going to make my mark by
basically shellacking them over and over
and over
so that's why he walked back the
bipartisan deal after weeks of closed
door negotiations according to the new
york times mr biden strode to the
cameras on white house driveway on
thursday
flanked by an equal number of democratic
and republican lawmakers to proudly
announce an overall
infrastructure agreement totaling 1.2
trillion dollars over eight years that
could cement his legacy as a bipartisan
deal maker
biden and his top eights had
successfully struck a limited agreement
with key central senators to rebuild
roads and bridges while carefully
signaling the liberals he still intended
to embrace a measure likely to gain only
democratic support to spend trillions
more
on climate education child care and
other economic priorities it was and i
told you so a moment for a president
who's supremely confident in his ability
to navigate legislative negotiations but
in a stray comment during a news
conference an hour later the president
blurted out he would not approve the
compromise
without the partisan bill he said if
that's the only thing that comes to me
i'm not finding it
i'm not signing the bipartisan bill and
forgetting about
the rest come on man
it may not seem like much says the new
york times it was enough to upend
biden's proud bipartisan moment
on the one hand he was saying out loud
what liberals in his party wanted to
hear that's the center of senators and
republicans
it made explicit a notion that had only
been hinted at before that biden not
only intended to sign a second more
ambitious package but that he would also
go so far as to veto their bipartisan
plan
if the larger bill did not materialize
senator susan collins said we never had
an inkling that would be any kind of
linkage
we always knew there'd be another bill
but not that the success of the
infrastructure package was going to be
in any way
dependent on the other bill so the white
house had to engage in damage control
and then they had to walk it back
and then biden had to concede that he
had misspoken he had not misspoken guys
he's saying the quiet part out loud
which is that he intends to shiv
republicans directly in the back which
is why they never should have gone along
with this dumb deal
in the first place mitt romney always of
generous spirits
suggested of course that now he takes
biden at his word that he's de-linking
the two issues
i do take the president at his word and
and over the weeks and weeks of
negotiations with democrats and with the
white house
on an infrastructure bill uh the the
president's other agenda was never
linked to the infrastructure effort uh
we came to an agreement on the
infrastructure effort in a way that
i think is really impressive as you know
uh it it is true
infrastructure bridges roads rail
electric uh utility support and so forth
and uh and without raising taxes and so
this is a bill which stands on its own
okay well we'll see if the bill stands
on its own or if joe manchin and kristen
cinema are just going to quietly go
along with what it was that biden was
saying in the first place
and the democrats let the democrats own
it i don't understand why republicans
would work with these people just
don't give them what they want don't
give them the veneer of bipartisanship
on what is
a heavily partisan agenda and you say oh
well you know we saved over the course
of a decade
200 billion dollars okay and you also
gave
him the political wins that he can go
out and continue to win on the basis of
a lie which is that he's a bipartisan
president when he very much
is not who's got two thumbs and wants
you to like and subscribe